hey guys it's evan and today i want to
share with you a website that i love
using it's free it saves me a lot of
time and frustration and headache
and i don't think i've talked about it
before so it's called saluto and it's
saluto.com
and what it allows you to do is manage
your own computers
as well as other people who you have to
support in your network so
for me i've lined up uh my own computer
so using hp at the office i have a mac
at home
i have another sony at home that i
haven't used apparently for two months
so thank you for telling me that
and in the past i've also had my mom on
here i've had my dad on here so you can
manage
other people's computers as well if
you're the most technology savvy person
in your family or in your business i
think you can manage up to five
computers at once
for free which is what i'm on until uh
you can then expand to a paid program
why is this so cool so let me show you
what i use it for i'll click on my
computer now this is what i'm using
right
now and basically what it does it tells
you everything you need to know about
your computer so you can see
that uh while it's old so usually i
don't go more than two years without a
new computer so this one's lasting me
maybe thanks to uh
to saluto so this is okay like the stuff
that tells you about your computer is
okay
you know it tells me my ram cpu all that
fun stuff how much space i have if it's
fragmented or not
you know how much space is free blah
blah blah okay this part is pretty cool
where it can tell you what apps you have
what programs you have that are
out of date that need to be updated that
there are versions available so i have
winrar
audacity vlc java and skydrive that are
all
out of date and i can just click update
all and it'll update them all
automatically on my computer for me so i
can click update all
and then it's going to go and
automatically update everything for me
which is great i don't have to worry
about if i have software that's out of
data anymore
lower down this is what i loved it for
this is the gold behind saluto in my
mind at least
what it does is it helps you understand
when you load your computer i don't know
if you have this problem i had it a lot
before sudo i loaded my computer
and it loaded all sorts of apps in the
background all sorts of programs in the
background that i didn't need
i didn't want you know when you buy a
new computer it comes installed with all
sorts of software
that you're never going to need and you
don't know what it is and you're afraid
to remove it because you don't know what
it does on your computer unless you're
super tech savvy which i'm not
it takes up space it takes up you know
memory
it slows down your computer so how do
you know what to get rid of
so this is where sudo comes in handy so
my boot sequence
will run 53 background apps so before my
computer
is fully loaded it has to load 53
different things and it takes me three
and a half minutes
for my computer to load up so that
actually is pretty long maybe i need to
look it now at that new computer
but it's gonna tell me what i can
potentially remove now this is zero
uh that i should remove what i can
potentially remove
what are required apps and i can't
remove and what i have removed so
i have removed 28 programs
from my computer thanks to saluto that
that cost my computer three minutes of
boot time so i've cut my boot time in
half i thought three and a half minutes
was long
it would be even longer if i didn't cut
these programs so what it does is show
you a list of the things
so for example google chrome wanted to
load automatically
and that adds a full minute a minute of
boot time
so with each program what it'll do is
you can click on it
and it'll show you what it is it gives
you an explanation and it gives you
options you can either delay it
you can which means it'll load
after your boot time so it'll boot up
let you run your computer and then it'll
load
you can have it in the boot or you can
pause it so it won't load unless you
click it to load
so chrome for example why do i need
chrome to load
automatically i'll load chrome when i
want to load a web browser i don't need
it to load
running in the background taking up my
memory and taking up
my boot time and time at the beginning
the great thing about it too here is it
also shows you what other people are
doing
so i picked this option which is
posit so that's a third of the people 11
percent just delay it and 56
of people actually have it in their boot
i don't know why you need it in your
boot
windows media player quicktime google
update all these things
you know that you may not understand
what they do like this one what the heck
is
quick share exe you know i don't know
but you can see most people
have it in their boot or they just
removed it
so you can kind of get a sense of what
the community is doing with it
so it's helped me take out three minutes
of my boot time so let's look at these
ones now this isn't that
important anymore right there's eight
things that could potentially remove
it's only 15 seconds of my boot time so
i can load it up
now some of the smaller ones uh they may
not have a description available right
so like
raw link 802.11 and wireless lan what
the heck is that i mean it connects to
the internet
somehow do i need that i don't know
description not available
most people keep it in their boot so i'm
probably going to do that
because i don't want to do something
that's going to harm my computer
windows live a suite of free
applications of bundle email instant
messaging photo sharing blog and
security devices and other windows live
programs
so recommendation if you use bundled
windows live programs keep it in boot if
you don't remove it so i don't use
windows live
so i can remove it from boot and save
myself 5.7 seconds
there you go so it tells you for each
one i'm going to go through these other
ones but it doesn't take a lot of time
for these so it's not a huge deal for me
right now
so that's why i love using saludo so you
can do this for yourself for your own
computer you can manage your other
computers
you can again make your boot time a lot
shorter but also make sure that your
your programs are all up to date and if
you are managing
more than one computer if it's for
yourself or for other people
right if you're managing your parents
computers or somebody in your business
then you could do it through saludo here
this is all free again i think it's up
to five computers
they do have a remote access feature too
which you do have to pay for which i
haven't used so i can't say if it's good
or not but basically if i'm running my
computer
and then i'm running my dad's computer
and he's having a problem with it
doesn't know how to fix it i could just
click here
go remote access connect to his computer
and fix whatever i need to do
anyway uh great program love using it
awesome website
pretty simple interface intuitive easy
to use
saves me a lot of time saves me a lot of
frustration i recommend checking it out
i have no connection to the company
apart from being a user and i love it
and i think you should check it out
so enjoy for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below
let me know what you think you if you
like this video you have something to
say leave it below
you have a question for me about saludo
or another website or about your
business leave in the comments let me
give you a reply
thank you so much guys and i'll see you
soon